oh isn't that nice that's not a mistake
you know that guy has a little poster
yeah Mary what does it say oh my
goodness is that in Russian that's in
Russian okay you speak Russian but I
don't read it you idiot
you were almost there weren't you you
were sunny oh so close
he researched everything thank you so
much for being here thanks for having me
I saw I saw us the other night
absolutely loved it a bunch of us went
and saw the movie it's visually stunning
it's just fantastic and and you're great
and beautiful as always in it were you a
Wizard of Oz fan when you were yeah I
can honestly say was the first book that
I read that was like a full-length book
in English was returned to us yeah and
and in the first movie that I remember
seeing was it was it of Oz and I spoke
about that like three years ago at a
portfolio for W Magazine but then get
this I realized throughout doing this
press that I was in The Wizard of Oz
play in fourth grade and just completely
forgot about it so somewhere there's
footage of me being the understudy to
Glinda the Good Witch oh really yes so
it's all come full circle now a little
bit yeah that's really cool and you know
it's funny cuz the sign and then you
mention it right here you you moved to
this country at what age seven and a
half you were seven and a half when you
moved here and so did you speak English
when you moved - no not a word I learned
English pretty quickly because I was
little yeah what did you speak when you
when you came Russian you spoke Russian
okay and so you learned pretty quickly
and because around the same time you
started working in commercials yeah I
started working when I was uh like nine
years old for a little network called
univisio you may have heard of it so the
number for that word what a fourth
Network I call it Univision um it's
French but how would you did you speak
enough English to be in commercials at
the time I spoke pretty fluent English I
would say like yeah clean cleaning
there's no accent nothing yeah
okay well sitter's we I haven't seen it
yet but we we found one of your some of
the work that you did this isn't a
commercial I think you were in the film
piranha Oh God I were on it and this is
your in piranha and
and this is that you'd only spoken a
nice for like two years at this point
but you say Giri well I would say I
think I was yeah pretty good look just
think in a couple days I'll be back home
where the only waters near Bath you're
not afraid of that - no idea
no that sounds like fine
[Applause]
I think you nailed it no problem with
that at all but seriously like now I
don't detect any accent at all yeah no
no that's pretty it's not that bad okay
can you can you bust out the Russian
though at any time when you have to yeah
to speak yeah if you got big if you
could you choose someone out in Russian
no not very wow I realized I'm not like
curse words and things like that like I
never really practiced enough yeah but
um but conversational speech yeah yeah
cuz it is a tough language when you hear
it but you know we had a comedian on the
show not long ago was talking about how
when you anything you say in Russian
just sounds great sounds really a I know
I've heard this from Americans
apparently when my dad and I have a
conversation about just how much we love
each other and everything's great we're
having a fantastic day it legitimately
sounds like Klingon well how about like
a few people worth to me my desert like
I love you honey
how's your day and apparently just
sounds like gibberish of yelling I'm
gonna get in trouble my assistant is
Armenian and she when she talks to her
parents on the phone she speaks English
beautifully of course she's born in this
country everything but when she talks
them on the phone it's like style though
see not bad deal yeah and I said that
sounds like to Dracula's yelling at each
other totally true I thought to me it's
loving and caring yeah and a beautiful
language and to most other people it
just sounds frightening